next question today hey David what would
an actual compromise border security
deal look like to get government
reopened but to actually do some stuff
on border security okay
number one on the list is that companies
who hire undocumented immigrants have to
be punished to the fullest extent of the
law so much of what we're dealing with
and so much of the problem is related to
the fact that no matter what the law
says corporations and companies are
rarely punished certainly not to the
fullest extent of the law for hiring
undocumented immigrants it has been an
incredibly successful ruse to convince
you to be mad at someone coming from
Latin America looking to improve their
circumstances and that of their family
to be mad at them rather than the
corporation who's taking advantage of
those people in order to lower how much
they pay in wages okay
so number one is we've got to go after
the corporations that has to be part of
any deal if you ask me what should be in
it
drones cameras and motion sensors
absolutely have to do it when you talk
about the number of miles of border that
we have when you remember that the ports
of entry are actually the places where
90% of the drugs are coming through you
need technological assistance rather
than just putting up a wall particularly
when only 1/3 of those who are coming
into the u.s. undocumented are
physically crossing the border and of
those one-third many are coming through
the border and asking for asylum ok
which is not against the law
we need more staffing for the ports of
entry where again most of the drugs are
coming through the ports of entry not
through areas of the border where we
would put a wall so we will catch more
smugglers of drugs and people and we can
also speed up that process because a lot
of those ports of entry you will spend
hours trying to get back into the United
States or into the United States if
you're coming from another country now
as far as that's what I would like to
see as far as what sort of compromise
might actually lead to a deal or what
Democrats could ask for in exchange for
5 billion to start the wall because
remember even if Trump gets the 5
billion today or tomorrow that's the
beginning of a process which will take a
long time and which the next president
can just stop okay that's a really
important thing to
I would be lobbying if I was a Democrat
and I was of the mindset that okay I
don't think the wall spending is a good
idea but if we can agree to give Trump
five billion in exchange for a whole
bunch of stuff that becomes policy
knowing that only a fraction of the wall
will be built and the next president
could stop this this is hypothetical I
would insist daca recipients must get a
very clear path to citizenship and it
has to be relatively quick we've got to
take them out of this legal limbo or
psychological limbo that they are in
we've got to establish something firm
for holding corporations accountable who
hire undocumented immigrants that's
going to be tough because you have a big
political donors who want to be able to
continue hiring undocumented immigrants
without getting punished we need more
immigration judges to speed up the
process you'd think both sides would
agree on that because the right says
they want people out more quickly when
they're going to be deported more
immigration judges would achieve that
the left doesn't want people in legal
limbo and detained in these de-facto
internment camps for any period of time
and more immigration judges would cut
down on the amount of time that they're
there so I think that those are elements
that could maybe lead to a compromise
and that Democrats could insist on but I
actually don't disagree with the
strategy of just holding out on this and
saying we're not going to give you money
for the wall I mean we're just we're
just not going to give you money for the
wall period if I'm missing some
component that you think would be an
important factor of such a compromise
and if you're just gonna write to me and
say we just need the wall we just
disagree right I'm looking to have a
more reasonable conversation with you
here let me know what else should be or
could be part of a package